good morning believe nation today's
message is keep innovating one step at a
time over to you Vinod Khosla TV go most
of the time when you start something you
want to do something meaningful and get
started and may be smaller but you want
to keep innovating building on it one
step at a time and hopefully it becomes
much larger you know amazon started with
just books now it's everything if you
look at twitter or facebook when they
started there were relatively small
things macaca was just trying to connect
everybody on the Harvard campus not
seven billion people on the planet but
he kept expanding his vision so very
often when you start with an innovative
idea you don't know how big it is in
fact most of most of the really
innovative ideas have been very hard to
predict what's a large opportunity or a
small opportunity so what do you think I
think that often times when you're
facing any kind of large challenger
innovation the the challenge looks too
big and so being able to make sure that
you're continually adopting but also
getting to work like getting to work on
things if you have software released the
software even if it's not fully done
innovate every step along the way don't
think about making things perfect before
pushing stuff out before starting the
job before doing anything innovation
every single step little bite-size steps
will certainly break big challenges down
but it'll also make sure that you have a
culture of innovation that you're
constantly innovating that you're not
being left behind and and I think
innovation is is key in any business I
was having an interesting discussion
this morning with somebody who's
starting a YouTube channel and he's
comparing his channel to mine and say
well look at all this stuff that you're
doing and he's not sure how he can copy
my success and do all the things that
I'm doing and I reminded him that
when I started I sucked like the first
videos I was brutal add like I couldn't
speak properly and was trying to
memorize sayings and you you help me
make some of the first ones you know
that was six years ago something like
that maybe longer and you may look back
and look at my channel then look at my
channel now look at the videos and the
quality and the effects and the intros
and the brand and all of that and how
much it's grown and you see a big gap
from where we've gone and that was all
step by step those were all little steps
that would you look at it accumulates to
be a big step and so I think a lot of
people that on to Mark's point see this
big gap between where you are where you
want to be that might be some big
unsurmountable step you don't know how
to take it but really it's going to be
doing little steps every day constantly
tweaking costly to get better and just
put yourself to be better than you were
yesterday even now my videos as good as
you guys may like them I still think
there's a lot of room for them to get
better and I'm not sure how they're
gonna get better but they're gonna get
better we're going to constantly tweak
them to improve them every day every day
every day it's a concept of Kaizen this
constant never-ending improvement you
know it reminds me of story I heard
someone as an adult said that they
wanted to learn guitar and someone else
said i can give you the secret to learn
guitar and he wrote down the secret and
essentially was practice every day and
the guy looked at it went yeah i'm not
going to do that but but that's all it
was if you want to learn guitar learn
guitar every day innovate every day get
better every day practice there's it's
not rocket science I like it it's a good
message Marc Jacob so the question of
the day today is what's the one excuse
that you have for why you're not
innovating and it better be an excuse
and you better realize that it's alive I
like that leave in the comments below
we're going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso hahaha that time I said it
expressive not even espresso expressed
yeah expressive but I would like to say
that the arm motion I think that was the
furthest reading so far that's what
threw me off I was feeling the energy
in the non CI put all of my energy and
thought in Saigon find them okay I guess
presso awake this brace hello keep me
going